eeuu solución en este país su única
derrota militar ocurrió en la década de
los 60 y 70 en la que fue una guerra
pero larga y muy impopular
tanto que terminó con la carrera
política del presidente demócrata lyndon
johnson y supuso de facto el fin del
modelo estadounidense de política
exterior vigente desde la segunda guerra
mundial
el horror vivido fue de tal dimensión
que provocó la rebelión de toda una
generación contra el imperio de la
fuerza y consiguió por ejemplo que las
guerras dejasen de ser populares en
hollywood desde entonces la memoria
colectiva se construyó a través de
películas denuncia cómo fueron platoon
la chaqueta metálica o 'apocalipsis now'
nadar en punto cuela si si lo has
adivinado hoy hablamos de vietnam un
país que marcó un antes y un después en
la historia de eeuu en este vídeo te
contamos que ha ocurrido desde entonces
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pues lo contamos en un vídeo anterior
vietnam es el país del mundo donde más
apoyo popular tiene el capitalismo en
concreto según datos del pew research
center el 93% de la población considera
que el libre mercado es el mejor modelo
posible un porcentaje muy superior al
que registra cualquier potencia
occidental
si amigos aunque resulte chocante hoy el
capitalismo y el libre mercado es más
popular en vietnam que en los mismísimos
estados unidos es en la demostración de
que el capitalismo es el mejor de los
sistemas del capitalismo demás salva
bien veamos por qué
el despegue de vietnam
en sólo unas pocas décadas vietnam ha
experimentado una transformación enorme
ha pasado de ser una sociedad agrícola a
convertirse en una pujante nación
industrial desde el año 2000 este país
ha vivido un auténtico boom económico y
su crecimiento anual medio ha sido de
casi el 7% al tiempo que la capacidad de
consumo de sus habitantes se ha
multiplicado por 6 en poco más de 15
años no está mal verdad es una gran
industria en lo que se refiere a
inversión producción de equipos
transferencia de conocimientos educación
y por otra parte es desde luego una gran
oportunidad para el intercambio también
en materia deportiva cultural y en otros
sectores kaiser cada vez son más las
multinacionales que anuncian inversiones
millonarias en este país por ejemplo
agarrados a la silla tan solo samsung ha
anunciado inversiones en este país por
valor de 20 mil millones de dólares casi
nada
lo siento mucho ese tipo
según pricewaterhousecoopers también
conocidos como el house water watch
cooper coaching se convertirá en una de
las principales ciudades del mundo en
apenas una o dos décadas y será una de
las dos ciudades que más crecerán de
aquí a 2025 así que si aún no tenéis
claro dónde está esta ciudad o queréis
hacer negocios ya la podéis buscar en el
mapa pero seguro que os preguntaréis no
es acaso vietnam un país comunista es
ésta una especie de triunfo del
comunismo pues no del todo
el comunismo en vietnam si es verdad
oficialmente el país continúa siendo una
dictadura comunista pero podemos decir
que su modelo de apertura a la inversión
y al comercio exterior es muy similar al
que experimentó china tras las reformas
de deng xiaoping de las que por cierto
fonseca nos habló en este vídeo así es
que qué hizo den xiaoping pues cambiará
el sistema político a trocitos y así es
como surgió la idea de las zonas
económicas especiales pero regresemos a
vietnam aunque el país se haya abierto
al comercio y la inversión exterior es
cierto que aún muchas empresas siguen
siendo propiedad del gobierno
concretamente casi la mitad de las 500
mayores empresas del país pero por otro
lado también es verdad que cada vez son
más numerosos los planes para privatizar
muchas de estas empresas y ojo el
régimen vietnamita lo hace de una forma
muy capitalista en vez de buscar a
multinacionales para vender las empresas
públicas como es muy común por ejemplo
en latinoamérica en vietnam el gobierno
por lo genera la saca a cotizar en su
particular wall street la bolsa de ho
chi minh
[Música]
de esta forma cualquier persona puede
apostar por invertir en estas compañías
y desde luego el modelo es más
transparente consigue mejor la
recaudación del estado y no destruye la
competencia también hay otras
diferencias con china por ejemplo aunque
las exportaciones y las inversiones
industriales van viento en popa el
gobierno británica también ha dado
prioridad desde el principio a otras
áreas más ligadas a los servicios como
por ejemplo el turismo sin duda la mejor
muestra de todo esto es jugo island una
isla casi del tamaño de singapur que el
gobierno tiene convertir en una meca
internacional del turismo y el ocio
y para ello claro está ha confiado en el
mercado internacional aquí los turistas
no necesitan una visa para entrar el
gobierno ha construido modernas
infraestructuras y se han dado muchas
facilidades a que los inversores
internacionales lleguen con su dinero el
resultado es un impresionante boom de
hoteles resorts apartamentos parques
temáticos e incluso un casino los
proyectos en marcha se acercan a los 200
y las inversiones ya superan los 6 mil
millones de dólares desde luego ya os
podéis imaginar que las perspectivas son
ahora brillantes para los habitantes de
la isla que hasta ahora sobrevivían
gracias prácticamente a una pesca de
subsistencia y no sólo es eso la llegada
de turistas internacionales es un buen
conductor para nuevas ideas que
favorecen el aperturismo y el
entendimiento si amigos de visual
político durante los próximos años
vietnam dará mucho de qué hablar y en
washington lo saben
el dt
obama y la apuesta por vietnam ya lo
sabéis es algo sobre lo que insistimos
bastante durante sus ocho años en la
casa blanca barack obama apostó fuerte
por el sudeste asiático y hay que decir
que vietnam fue uno de sus objetivos
procedentes de hecho el propio barack
obama visitó este país para dar un
carpetazo definitivo a las hostilidades
heredadas de la guerra no fue el primer
presidente en hacerlo tanto bill clinton
como george bush ya lo habían visitado
previamente pero obama ha sido
probablemente de los tres el que mejores
resultados logró obama logró la adhesión
de vietnam al famoso de pepe levantó el
embargo a la venta de equipos militares
a este país y nos dejó imágenes como
ésta
y en su búsqueda por lograr una estrecha
alianza con vietnam algo en lo que por
cierto tuvo éxito obama llegó a recibir
en la casa blanca al mismísimo
secretario general del partido comunista
chino así que sí para sorpresa de muchos
hay que decir que hoy vietnam el nuevo
tigre estético es ya un aliado
estratégico de eeuu en fin qué pensáis
vosotros se convertirá a vietnam en una
nueva potencia asiática logrará donald
trump mantener la estrecha alianza
generada entre este país y eeuu
esperamos que os haya gustado este vídeo
y aún no sabes que es este botón es la
nueva versión de ellos al político en
inglés así que si quieres repasar la
lengua de shakespeare no dudes en hacer
clic y suscribirte y si tienes algún
amigo angloparlante ya sabes
recomiéndanos un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]